The variance is a measure of how far the data is spread.
It's really small if the data is centered around the mean,
and it's really large if the data falls far away from the mean.
Here are two trees, and both of these trees have a couple of apples
Of course, the apples at some point fall down.
When they're on the ground, then all of them are centered equally around the stem of the tree,
so if you computed the mean you would get back exactly where the stem of the tree is.
But on the wide tree, the spread is much larger,
whereas for the small tree, the spread is much smaller.
You can think of variance as a measure of how wide the tree is from which the apples fell down.